and now b3 and of course black wins big
captures special characters and after
this captures here you will not be able
to move this rook for the rest of your
game and there are so many ways to win
this for black the simplest one is just
bring your king over to a to win the
rook and black white is helpless to stop
it
so I also sorry about that for not
mentioning it it is an important line I
was gonna mention it but like I said I
just forgot so that's about to the
previous video but now we return to this
video course on vs. Nakamura with the
white pieces were really an exciting
game so let's just check it out Magnus
opens with d4 with Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to f3 and d5 we have the Queens
gambit declined Knight to c3 and Bishop
to e7 with Bishop to f4 magnus continues
in the same fashion as he did against
well Fabiano Khurana in their 2018 World
Championship match with castles by
Nakamura and now III again following the
game costomers Caruana in for example
game 2 in the World Chess Championship
match 2018 in London c5 by Nakamura D
captures on c5 Bishop captures on c5 and
now a3 with Knight to c6 ok it's a bit
bit different because here instead of a
three Magnus went Queen to c2 but again
we transpose into the same game they
played in London a three knife to c6 and
now Queen to c2 so the position is the
same differences here Fabiano played
Queen to a5 in London and then we had
the the very exciting line where Fabiano
surprised the Magnus with rook to DA the
very old old line he basically
rejuvenated and brought into the waters
championship but here the nakamura goes
rook to e8 it's a line that he's known
to play but it's also a line that Magnus
knows very well and it's basically why I
chose this title for this video because
here with Bishop to g8
now fighting for the center controlling
the knight here as it's pinned with
Bishop back to e7 by Nakamura and here
we have looked d1 and here there's only
one game that was played in this line up
until this moment
it is in fact Vishwanathan Anand versus
calls in 2014 in Sochi Russia the World
Chess Championship match game 8 which
ended in a draw but it's very
interesting Nakamura chose to play this
line against cross and and well I don't
know who would know this line better
than Carlsen
even though Carlson had the black pieces
in that game Anand had the white pieces
but ok here with Queen to a5 the the
same move Carson played against Anand in
the 2014 World Chess Championship match
we haven't covered that game as we only
covered the dare 2013 match were Magnus
won his title we haven't covered the the
2014 one but we will at some point and
probably when I will be doing that match
we will mention this game you know just
for fun with Bishop to d3 here
Magnus plays the same line the same move
Anand played against him in the 2014
versus champion match and here we have a
bit of a difference here we have h6 by
nakamura which is sorry
in that game cross and played h6 against
Anand but here we have D captures and c4
so Nakamura plays a new move and ok with
Bishop captures on c4 with h6 now asking
the bishop where you're gonna go do you
want to go to f4 you want to go to h4 or
maybe you want to capture on f6 of
course you don't want to capture on f6
give up your Bishop pair so with rush up
to f4 and now Bishop to d7 Nakamura
continues developing with castles by
Magnus and now rook a to c8 a very nice
move aligning your rook with the Queen
and c2 also with the bishop on c4 that's
undefended and now efore by Magnus
so what do you do here of course here
Nakamura would like to do some nice
nasty discovery for example my DD 4
would be ok as it attacks the Queen also
it attacks the bishop the problem is if
rook captures you just lose the piece as
the rook also guards the bishop on c4 so
not something you want to do so after
efore first nakamura creates an outpost
for the knight on d4 with E 5 creates an
outpost for tonight also does so without
wasting time as the bishop on f4 is
under attack
with the shakhter III and only now
Nakamura finds a way to trade more
pieces with Bishop to death or sorry
knighted before and now you have to
react to this as your queen and c2 is
under attack
so Bishop captures with rook captures
and c4 now keeping the bishop here on
pre with Bishop captures on e5 and now
what do you do here Nakamura sorry
Carlsen just grabbed a pawn here so what
can Nakamura do Nakamura finds a very
nice idea of course you cannot play
Knight captures on e4 even though the
knight on c3 is pinned because your
Bishop here is hanging so here not Maura
finds a very nice plan first Bishop to a
for attacking the Queen and the rook and
Magnus has to defend of course the only
defense is b3 so this is what Magnus
does and now you get Knight captures on
e4 winning back at the pond and asking
Magnus what do you wanna do here so here
at Magnus has a couple of options
Queen t2 is well the strongest one but
the one Magnus didn't find he mentions
this in an interview because then he had
access to the engine so Queen e2 is a
very nice land because then you get to
rook captures on c3 and after B captures
on e4 now rook the c5 with a double
attack against the bishop here but now
Bishop captures on g7 this is what you
had to find an after King captures Queen
captures here and you get this position
where White is still up a pawn but
doesn't really matter it so doubled upon
but blacks King side structure is all
messed up so which would be the better
for Magnus but Magnus finds a different
one he plays rook the d3 puts more
defenders to the c3 square and now rook
eat the c8 my Nakamura bringing more
pressure to the C file Queen to b2 by
Magnus the strongest move getting the
Queen out of the way also putting more
pressure to the g7 pawn and now what do
you play here here Nakamura has to
decide whether he wants to trade down
into an endgame which of course is
possible with rook captures on c3 and
after Bishop captures you can just trade
everything you can go rook captures rook
captures Queen captures on c3 Queen
captures Knight captures and here after
be captures on a4 you will capture with
the night and here nakamura would have
pressure against the a3 pawn and he
could go into this meeting and exchange
down with
to connect at points on the queenside
but he decides against it here after
queen-to-be to Nakamura decides to mix
it up
he plays tonight's the c5 attacks
Carlson's Knight Luke on e3 and here
rook to e3 just getting the rock out of
the way and here Nakamura plays Bishop
captures on b3 which is a very nice move
and now it's Magnus to play well of
course it's also you to play so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find a good move for white in this
really messy position while I give you a
couple of seconds of course for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
snatcher of pawns on g7 and for the Duke
who just won't enjoy the show Bishop
captures on g7 is the idea here what
happens well of course you cannot
capture this because after 95 check
everything falls apart you're in check
there's the double attack against the
bishop here King h7 you just get rook
captures on e7 in there are so many
threats here for white you would just
fall apart would black so after Bishop
captures ng7
Nakamura played rook to g4 putting
pressure on the g2 pawn and also
attacking the bishop here and I'm not
gonna said that he missed this move but
he didn't feel all that worried about it
he just played Bishop captures on h6
getting the best part of the way
grabbing yet another pawn and here with
Bishop f6 by Nakamura oh I mean the
bishop with the Queen and b2 also
putting more pressure on the knight on
c3
which is you know in a lot of ways the
theme of this game and Nakamura putting
pressure on c3 and Magnus trying to work
around it with nicely 5 by Magnus and
not what do you play here you don't
really have a good square for your rook
here you kind of want to keep your rook
on the G file but there's no room for
the rook on the G file so you have to
move it away from the G file the problem
is if you move it away from the G file
then white has too many threats along
the G file Rho G 3 check and black falls
apart King h7 now at Queen B 1 check you
sacrifice the bishop but only
temporarily you don't mind sacrificing
the bishop for a nice mating attack
Queen to a5 and now there are too many
threats you're threatening to capture
the bishop but also there are
many other threats for example if Bishop
captures here eaters gonna check me the
black king queen g5 check and here you
will just have a nice mate
so black cannot allow this so of course
he captures the monster night with
Bishop capture 75 rook captures on e5
and now Queen to b6 unpinning and also
preparing to capture the bishop here
Magnus defends it we have Queen to d2
now guarding the bishop here and
nakamura brings the rook back into the
defense but also with a double attack
against the bishop here magnus retreats
Bishop to e3
now again putting pressure and pinning
the night here and now Queen to c6
unpinning again and also threatening
mate so what can cross and do about this
here Crossing plays Knight to d5 and
it's really just one of those nice moves
that I'm gonna use as a thumbnail as
he's threatened unites the seven which
just creates a monster for cure
everything is connected so you have to
react to this
there's no no way around it so of course
nakamura captures it with Bishop
captures on d5 and now just the Queen
captures on d5 Magnus offers a queen
trade and nakamura is not all that happy
about it so first b6 puts the defender
here to the c5 Knight but now g3 Magnus
also doesn't want to constantly keep an
eye on this pressure on the G file with
Knight to d7 attacking the rook and now
Magnus just trades with Queen captures
rook G captures on c6 at the same time
doubling up on the C file and now after
all is said and done Magnus is up upon
but more importantly he is three to one
advantage on the King side will be well
hard to deal with for Nakamura and also
there's play on both sides of the board
Magnus has a bishop so Bishop is a bit
more useful than a knight when when
there's play on both sides of the board
with rook to d5 first attacking the
knight and now Knight back to f8 and
here rook F to D one
Magnus doubles on the D file with
Knights to e6 now Nakamura increases the
activity of the night and now a for
Magnus goes for a5 who wants to break
well this very nice harmony of the two
connected points on the Queen side we've
looked a c4 attacking the pawn and now
just looked
five of course Magnus wants to get rid
of his phone and leave black with only
one point on the queenside we've looked
to be for defending on v6 but now just
rook to d7 threatening to capture an a7
of course if you push a six then of
course Magnus will capture on v6 so here
you have to trade we have B captures on
a5 roof captures on a7 and now a for
Nakamura pushes the past pawn but it
will be very hard to push it any further
as its Magnus who has a room behind the
past point so it's kind of kind of
difficult to get it going
look D to d7 and by Magnus and what do
you do now of course there are threats
of capturing an f7 and if you capture
this point then the three connected
passports are just too much to deal with
we've looked at d8 by Nakamura defending
if seven and now comes look to d5 by
Magnus Knight back to e6 and here rook
dita a5 Magnus doubles up on the a file
and threatens to capture on a4 Nakamura
of course defense but by defending this
puts both of Nakamura's rooks in a
pretty passive position so you're not
well it's even if the knight and the
bishop get traded off your rooks are
very passive here so here cross and just
play King to g2 and believe it or not it
was in this position that he Cara
Nakamura resigned to the the game might
seem a bit premature you know resigning
a game has it there's still so much
going on but black doesn't really have
all that much to play here and of course
Nakamura is you know a super grandmaster
he knows this and he doesn't want to
play it out one way to show this for
example if black continues the game you
cannot move the rooks from the B or C
file as you would lose the a4 pawn so
what can you play you can try some King
g6 try and improve your Kings position
and white will play h4 you're gonna look
into g6 now you're gonna get h5 now you
have to go back King of 6 now you're
gonna go King to h3 so again what can
black play you can't move the roof away
from the fourth rank you can go rookie 4
white is just gonna now double up rooks
on the seventh rack a rank a roof d7 you
can play rook to b8 prepare ruptor
it is you want to protect the f7 pawn
let's say rook a7 now going after the
pawn rook F 8 and now G 4 and black
really doesn't have all that many moves
you're pretty much controlling
everything here you can go King g7
you're gonna get g5 Knight bit of nicely
guards the g5 pawn king g8 you're gonna
get h6 and black doesn't have anything
to play rook the c4
you're gonna go rook to e7 and I don't
know rook to e4 preventing rook captures
on e6 as this is a pretty big threat but
after king g3 black again has to make a
move if you move this rook you're gonna
lose the f7 pawn if you move the knight
yeah white straight down into a
favorable endgame if you move the pawn
you lose the pawn and basically what you
have left is just to move this rook and
keep an eye on this pawn but then rook
captures an e6 happens and black falls
apart F captures now you get the g6 and
you're getting made it you don't want to
allow h6 in g h7 and g7 or to come with
check and end winning of the rook so
let's say rook d8 but then you get
Bishop g5 you attack the route and now
it's over a couple of more checks and
there are no more moves left King G to
rock g4 check King here you can play
here King e2 and now you have to decide
either you give up the rook or it's rook
to e8 checkmate there's nothing much to
do here and this is basically with
perfect play but in any other way
Magnus would you just win this and of
course Nakamura knows this and he
doesn't even make an attempt to try
anything here in this position against
the world champion sure that's basically
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
like I said it's only one of the games
that we're gonna show it was a very
eventful round so I will have to think
carefully which is the next game I'm
gonna show tomorrow morning but I do
have a pretty pretty strong feeling
about the next game and what we're
really hoping I'm not hoping but what
we're really looking forward to seeing
in round 7 is Magnus Carlsen against
Jana Pony she as cousin will have to
face his nemesis with the black pieces
and so far of course you know that
Magnus Carlsen has never defeated the on
Epona she in classical time format
they've drawn 5 games
nipple beat Magnus four times but Magnus
has never defeated the an opponent so
we'll see it's gonna be I'm sure it's
gonna be a really crazy game as nepo has
white and nipple does not waste the
white pieces nipple always likes to
party so it's really gonna be great
really looking forward to it but before
that like I said we're gonna show at
least one more game from this round
really it's gonna be awesome
Maria Oh once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank ed warm
old Simon Johansen Manuel but knock
French hilber and Tim Garvin for a
conversion to my channel think you ought
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see soon
continuing the creation Grantchester
coverage checking up in your suggestions
and it's it's unlikely that I will get a
chance to continue the couple Blanca
saga while this is going on but who
knows maybe I will so thank you I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your Monday